Just weeks after announcing his triumphant
return as Superman, Henry Cavill had to take
it all back. Here's how some DC diehards
are fighting the studio's decision.
When the news first dropped that director
James Gunn and producer Peter Safran would
take charge of the DC film universe, under
new Warner Bros. Discovery CEO David Zaslav,
it was implied that the duo would attempt to steer
the franchise in something of a new direction.
In one surprising move under their stewardship,
longtime DC Superman actor Henry Cavill revealed
that he's Superman no longer — though a
new "Superman" movie is planned, and Gunn
intends to maintain a working relationship with
Cavill moving forward. Gunn posted on Twitter,
On Instagram, Cavill shared,
Now that Cavill is a free agent, fans of
other major movie franchises have begun
to propose ideas for his next big role. For
instance, some want Cavill to join the MCU,
given his superhero experience and,
presumably, his superhero movie-ready physique.
Meanwhile, others think Cavill is a good fit for
James Bond, especially with the role's current
vacancy in mind. Of course, Cavill may instead
separate himself from franchise films entirely,
with his "Superman" exit following his
departure from Netflix's "The Witcher."
"Enjoy your last walk across the
meadow, and through the mist."
Whatever his future may be, plenty of fans
are, unsurprisingly, unhappy about Cavill's
departure. In fact, some are going so far as
to call for Gunn's head over the decision.
Soon after Henry Cavill's departure
from the DC film universe broke,
users on Twitter began to share
their disappointment with James Gunn
specifically over the news under
the hashtag #FireJamesGunn.
One user shared a screenshot of Cavill's
Instagram post confirming his departure
with the caption "#FireJamesGunn pass it on."
Meanwhile, in another post utilizing the hashtag,
another user argued that this news is
particularly disappointing given both
Cavill's apparent interest in remaining Superman,
and the fact that "Black Adam" seemed to tease a
future Cavill Superman storyline upon its
release about a month and a half prior.
"Black Adam. We should talk."
The hashtag has generated plenty of
discussion beyond just these posts too,
to the extent that the conversation has
reached at least one additional platform.
Eventually, discussion of James Gunn's firing
over his decision to proceed without Henry Cavill
reached enough of a critical mass that someone
started a Change.org petition for the cause.
This petition names Warner Bros. Discovery
CEO David Zaslav as its intended audience,
urging him to rehire Cavill and fire
Gunn, arguing that Cavill is a bonafide
movie star and capable of generating more
revenue than Gunn can as one of DC's leads.
As of the making of this video, the petition has
garnered 500 signatures and climbing. While such
a petition is unlikely to influence Zaslav or
affect Cavill's career, the amount of signatures
it ultimately receives can nevertheless serve
as a measure of the degree to which those upset
about Cavill's firing think that Gunn's
job should be impacted by this decision.
Of course, these sentiments aren't reflective of
DC film fans as a whole, but are, nevertheless,
in steady circulation following
the Cavill news. Gunn and Peter
Safran are still at the start of their DC
journey, so once the DC film universe has
time to develop under their guidance,
such sentiments could very well change.